oh I know how to kick this off there it
is
[Music]
that was so much better
welcome to episode 166 of the corridor
cast no side whistle on that yeah no I
think it was a slide whistle and it was
everybody else I think that's what we
learned Marty told us to lose the slide
whistle okay okay
something that's very exciting to all of
us
Halo short if you guys haven't seen it
by now hop on over to the crew Channel
check it out it's fantastic these guys
put together an awesome trailer for it
and we're gonna get into the meat and
potatoes of it everything that happened
since always everything
what can I say you know what I mean I am
a meat man so yeah I think uh you know
obviously the response has been like
tremendous seeing it from the outside
looking in it's like super exciting
because I've been watching you guys do
this for months like under the cover of
night putting in your own hours like
very much a passion project from the
ground up you know I feel like since
I've known you better I've seen you
working on like little Halo shots yeah
yeah I remember when you you know guys
first brought it up in the first place
and you're like super excited about it
and like to think of all the Manpower
that you guys poured into this thing to
produce this trailer and to see it blow
up in that way like everybody wanting to
throw their pee-pee at it you know which
you know if you're not on the corridor
website that's the producer points I'm
not weird I am weird but uh but yeah no
it's it's like really encouraging I mean
I want to hear your guys thoughts on
like the response and and how that makes
you feel after all these these hours and
hours and hours and hours that you put
in yeah man I don't know it
it's a little different for me like
Fenner has you've seen Fender's face a
lot I'm usually the guy shooting Fenner
um or recording him so recording me not
shooting him yeah not shooting you yeah
um
so for me it's been absolutely surreal
like I I was talking to you like the day
after and I was like this is like you
know I grew up watching this Channel and
and to not only be in a video but for
the project that we collaborated on be
the substance of that video it's
incredibly humbling and and
fortunately people liked it um yeah and
and that's even more meaningful um but
even outside of that just to be able to
share something that we made this is
just super special yeah it was really
cool for me Halo is very near and dear
to my heart and always been something I
wanted to do I was texting my buddy this
week because we uh back in like
I don't know grade eight or something in
high school we're like we should make a
Halo movie and we he had an old Jeep and
we uh try to turn it into a warthog
which I found an old photo of that Dean
used in the video that was so good I was
texting him I was like dude check this
out he's like holy [__] you did it how
far into the Jeep did you get we
basically stripped the whole thing and
like repainted the whole like chassis
and then we were just kind of like uh
we're we barely have our driver's
license it's the rule is it's not a real
warthog until you flip it and reflip it
yeah
no this was his it was his dad's old
rally Jeep so that thing had been
flipped so many times yeah had one of
the Halo games just come out or
something Halo Reach beta was going on
at the same time so we'd work on the
Jeep during the day and then go inside
crush a bucket of KFC and just play the
Halo Reach beta and it was it was
amazing good times man but yeah he's a
big music guy so I sent him the comment
from Marty and he was like my god well
yeah so wait yeah explain the context
there yeah so Martin O'Donnell one of
the original creators of Halo he was the
one that composed well with uh Michael
Salvatore is that the other guy composed
all of the incredible music that Halo is
so well known for and he commented on
the video and was like a fan except for
the slide whistle and our singing but
yeah but hopefully we redeemed ourselves
a little bit Marty if you're out there
we would love some choir lessons
come on down yeah that's pretty surreal
to think like because again it's very
easy when we're here to forget that
other people see the work yeah that
we're doing we were passing it to each
other like as friends and stuff and
going oh check this out check this out
yeah it's been super cool and like I saw
some comments this person was like I
work at 343 like everyone around the
studio absolutely loves this I saw it
randomly today on the Halo subreddit
there was a meme that I saw about us
you know the classic like uh Tony Stark
built this in a cave with a box of
scraps but it's yelling at Paramount and
it's like Corridor crew built this in a
cave with a box of scraps and I was like
wow that's weird that's us yeah I mean I
I you know I was a big big halo fan when
it first came out I have a lot of bad
takes in my life like a lot of bad takes
one of them was that the iPad would
never be popular I was like who would
want a big phone like that's dumb to be
fair I think people would have agreed
with you yeah I was wrong I also when
the Xbox originally came out I saw the
original Halo trailer and I said bust
and it turned out to be my favorite game
so you know don't listen to me but I I
love the franchise but I fell off like
around Halo 4. I think it was just
something a lot of people did yeah you
know
um and then when the Halo show came out
I felt so like removed from the IP that
I never watched it but you guys showed
it me some clips yeah and I am I'm
floored just from what I've seen I'm I'm
like not interested not even remotely
interested
um especially when contrasting with some
of the other stuff that you've shown me
from Halo like uh who was it that made
the oh the Neil Blom camera stuff is the
gold standard that stuff it's like
gritty it's you feel like you're in it
you know there's danger and it feels
like I mean tell me how much of a
motivator was that for the tone of what
you guys are building here big time man
me and Jonah had a lot of nights where
we'd go home
have some whiskey watch old Halo
trailers watch different films and be
like okay we want to emulate like
Alien aliens landfall
and uh Overlord we're kind of our main
Inspirations yeah silverlords was like
when we had we're first talking about
the project I was like I kind of think
this is a really good reference and you
had never seen it and you watched it and
you're like yep that's it yeah like have
you guys seen the movie it's a Bad Robot
Productions one I've done I don't know
is it the like World War One World no
Nazi zombies
it's so good totally flew under the
radar I feel like no one talks about
this movie it's got Wyatt Wyatt Russell
yeah and it's like the Nazi Zombie movie
we always wanted and just no one really
talks about it and it's got amazing like
body Horror in it and it's got like
really awesome battle stuff yeah and
it's all about like a small team going
into like a an abandoned yeah it does
the like rag tag Squad going into a base
thing very well which is kind of the
whole
you know breadth of the story that we're
trying to tell very character driven
which is cool yeah and when it comes to
actually like telling the story as big
of a script as you have like one of the
things that you've leaned on a lot
Fenner is
uh obviously the the assets available in
the blender Community which like as a
Houdini artist I'm very jealous of yeah
it's so cool that was the biggest like
aha moment for me was it was as we were
working on Stormtroopers I was like oh
someone's just said because originally
we like found that weird Russian website
that had all the assets so sketchy and
then I found a Discord that like had
them all set up in blender already and I
was like that's sick yeah and then I
found that for Halo and I was like oh my
God and that's the the Halo archive and
those guys commented on the videos yeah
they're so pumped they were like oh this
is amazing like
um and so that that was the moment like
it was kind of like the same month of
Stormtroopers
that we did that that I was like I want
to do the Halo thing look at all this
stuff like so that's when it started and
then it did like a super rough script
and then showed that to Jonah and Jonah
was like this is sick and then we kind
of just ended up writing it together and
Jonah really took the ball and just was
like started sprinting and then I was
like damn we should make this thing yeah
it was really cool for people who don't
know Jonah what was your role in this
like I would say like then I had this
like raw really raw idea and yeah I
don't want to like reveal exactly what
that idea was because it informs some of
the mystery of what we don't want to
talk about but my role really was taking
that right like really writing it out
for the first time and I was like all
right so you sent me like a Notes app
yeah a list of things that you wanted to
see and I I think the first version was
like
it was almost like 19 Pages yeah maybe
more that's right it was a challenge
yeah it was like and we had like five
people no I think it was six I think
there were six characters and then we
ended up we we took that through you
like you wrote it showed it to Sam and
Nico and then they were like cut this
thing in half which is a great note
honestly um yeah and it kept evolving so
my role has really been we've met with
Sam and Nico a bunch of times and taking
those notes and feedback and then
iterating and you know better and I'll
sit down and just talk through stuff we
would record we like recorded versions
of it on our phones uh just as voice and
we'd listen to them and then keep
turning and you know at this point I
want to say we're on version 14
um of the script and it's 14 pages I
think yeah lucky um but wait you got a
it's a 14 pages still yeah yeah so 14
pages which means I think at the end of
the day it'll probably be 10 minutes
okay nice yeah I'm
as a writer a bit uh descriptiony and
I'm aware of that I think I think for a
piece like this though it's appropriate
because we are we can't we don't have
the luxury of filming them so you have
to be descriptive in the actual script
to be like this is what it looks like
because you can't go location scout and
then be like that doesn't inform what
you're shooting the script is what's
informing what we're creating so that's
actually a really good point and yeah
from the beginning like that's what
really interested me with working uh in
this style of project which I haven't
done before is you know I I've made lots
of projects in the past where I'm out
and I'm going and I'm filming and
working with actors and you know that is
the form of filmmaking that comes
naturally to me and in the past I I
think I have used the act of filming as
a crutch to avoid uh getting really
really nitty-gritty into
how we're gonna shoot it I'll be like oh
we'll go I know that we're gonna get
some wide some tights it's gonna be
great and then because I come from
editing I'm like I'll figure it out like
I got this don't even worry about it
um which is lazy and like that's like an
amateur way to go about doing it and one
of the reasons I wanted to do this
project is
you know we aren't even using handles
like I tell Fenner the seconds of the
shot there's hands there shouldn't be
and it's my fault that I keep giving you
more but I know you're we've gone into a
scenario where there's no handles and
I'll just slow it down to like 80
because I need some frames look as VFX
artist Fred and I we've we've suffered
enough to always include handles no
matter what I always have handles what
that's forced me to do is like really
and that's been the second part of my
role is just being so so specific and
boarding out these very specific scenes
with reference imagery to lines and then
doing radio edits and getting those
working with the images we provided and
then providing what I can Defender and
then begging his forgiveness when I
don't give him exactly what he needs
um and that's been really exciting
because it's it's forcing me it's like
another film school because I can't
think about coverage I can only it's
like when we had patching on the podcast
he was like coverages for suckers and I
was like [__] right yeah that was
awesome that's cool yeah so that's
that's been the latter half of this
project well it's like I mean you guys
are basically making an anime I mean you
are making an animated film so it's like
it's um
it's a different it is a different style
of filmmaking like you're not capturing
real moments you're you're doing you're
you're basically putting your vision
directly on the screen and I think like
on a larger scale I feel like everybody
at Corridor is like in that headspace of
like we're just animators working with
like real people almost sometimes you
know what I mean
um like we're doing this anime video and
it's the same thing where it's like
every shot is
perfectly planned out beforehand and you
know with compositing and everything
it's like tweaking things afterwards and
yeah it's uh
I don't know that's the headspace I like
being into being like this is exactly
what I want and uh
you know Nico Nico kind of sometimes
will say like yeah actors are like
they're like puppets for your you know
your vision and um but yeah no it's it's
crazy that you guys have like
committed to just making a straight up
animated film yeah it's uh in your free
time yeah
it was a it was a blessing to get that
like two weeks to be like all right like
rock out a trailer for this and Jonah
basically went home that night and I was
like just chilling and then like two
hours later it's like come into my room
she was like check this out and he had
like the bones of the trailer like that
basically became what it was it's like
very similar yeah um which was insane
and then it was from there just being
like okay let's prioritize finishing
these shots because we had like we have
a bunch of the film actually done like
the whole intro is pretty much complete
and a bunch of sequences but this was
like the trailer forced us to be like
all right let's Jump Ahead six sequences
and just rock out like four shots to
that which has been great because it
kind of has defined how those sequences
will look forces me to have all the
environments set up all the characters
that will be in that setup and then now
it's a lot more feasible to make this
entire thing because it's basically just
drop our camera in blender lockout shots
do the motion capture so now it's just a
matter of doing them but it's feels like
very doable now which is nice yeah so
and as far as working with actors for
this this is obviously different since
it is all animated and virtual like
typically the actor's headspace it's
nice on set to be interacting with other
actors and yeah in this case I mean it's
JC upstairs Brett it's like Herman yeah
yeah who's in where does he live Norway
Norway there's no interaction with that
guy yeah there's no interaction with
these people and they don't have any
visual reference for what's going on
like how how did it how did you work
with that well originally we were just
for the sake of editing and blocking
this thing together we just wanted a
radio edit so we just sent the script to
the actors and they sent us back just
radio edits like blank line reads with
zero Direction and they nailed it like
first try and but obviously it's not
conversational so it's just kind of them
reading lines so it's uh like that was
when we were piecing together the
trailer we were kind of like okay we
just have to use the best lines that'll
kind of fit this scenario but they're
all out of order like someone will say a
line and then the other person reacting
but that's not actually how it is in the
script so ultimately once we are further
along in the production we would love to
get everyone in the same room so that
it's you're actually acting together
um but one of the coolest things was
um like JC because she's here like she
had done her radio edit and we had those
lines in the trailer and we were like I
I don't feel like the tone is correct
here because she was reading it with no
context but we'd had the trailer
complete at that point and so we're like
Hey JC let's go in the podcast room
right where we're sitting now we're
gonna bring up the trailer on the TV
this is what you're looking at and we
brought up the big shot at the end with
the the food and we gave her a gun and
then we were like oh that's cool yeah it
was really cool because we actually got
to director and then the lines that
ended up in the trailer were from that
little mo like vo session that was like
can you just record these three lines
and it was she just nailed it like
because she had the contacts in the
direction so that's been an awesome
learning experience because like I feel
like Herman and Brett they just had to
go in blind which is what we asked for
for the radio edit but and they did
amazing with what they gave us as well
so did you give them the full script or
did you give them like character notes
as well yeah who they were background
stuff no we were like we just want this
to be your interpretation oh wow it was
super intentional like we we had talked
beforehand because we've we've done it
so many times that we we think we know
that we we think we know these
characters a and we also think that we
know the best way to say the lines and I
was when when we were talking
we just we're like if we give them
nothing they're going to be honest in
their interpretation of it and they're
not going to Pander to like what we
think it is they're just gonna
see what's on the page they read
hopefully they read all the parts not
just their lines so they know the breath
of the story
is it good is it good if they just read
it and um that the goal is then now the
trailer's done to get them all in one
place yeah and do a stage play of it
okay so you guys are gonna do whole
thing again yeah together probably I
would say
I really like Herman's some apartments
lines they might stay in there but like
are they gonna do the mocap
I don't think so like just in terms of
like how we can actually coordinate all
that and just like because we are
working on this in our spare time it's
like
but it's cool I've just been kind of
doing mocap and mix them on where it
fits well and that's one of the benefits
of like like you were saying with the
Star Wars stuff like so many people do
these like uh Clone Trooper short films
now because it's like you don't have to
do faces yeah right they're wearing
helmets it's like the perfect thing to
do this for yeah where because it's like
you are you're working with game assets
but it looks like
pretty photo real in some shots yeah
because it's all hard surfaces and stuff
like that yeah and we definitely like I
mean you see in the trailer there's the
one shot of JC through the visor such a
cool thing from the we are ODST trailer
where you have that depolarization of
the lenses and we're definitely going to
play with that in like the emotional
moments of the story we'll have that
come through and that we want to have
the actual actors inside the helmets
because it's that shot of JC you're like
oh there's a person in there cool and
it's but we still also want to have that
little bit of like Mandalorian Vibe
where you're like who are these people
under so yeah you don't necessarily want
to reveal the actors until it's
you know if Mandalorian same thing as
the Halo show dude he takes off the
helmet first episode and it's like so
you don't care who's under there yeah
but Mandalorian such a big deal when you
took off yeah there's a mystery to it
yeah and it's like
we kind of want to do a little bit of
that as well and so it's a challenge for
sure remove their helmets or is that
spoiler maybe not I'll say this
by the end of the film you will see
multiple actors yeah faces yeah will you
see any butts like the Halo Master
cheeks
make an appearance Yeah man so but I was
gonna say that like you guys had a bunch
of like was it cosplayers like uh
there's like an ODST Community yeah
build like actual costumes who are like
who you know hit us up so I'm just
saying yeah no so I I talked to a few of
those people and because there is some
shot specifically where I'm like oh man
how are we gonna do this like someone's
spoiler someone's helmet comes off how
do we do that and I'm like man if we
just had practical play and you just
blend that with the CD like we did for
JC shot
um
another huge inspiration is love death
and robots I was just about to say that
Michael B Michael B Jordan episode where
it's like you have someone lying there
still and they're wearing a hard body
suit it's pretty easy to do the comp of
just like the head going like this kind
of thing yeah but hard to have that
helmet take off interaction so I'm like
man if we have a practical helmet and
pull that off and then it's reveal of
like an actual actor underneath that's
pretty pretty damn cool dude that'd be
so rad yeah and that's so cool because
it like sells the rest of the short as
like people were like oh my God this is
real and that might be something where
we have the actor in the motion capture
suit and we pull so that the body is the
same it's like actually what we have and
you just line up the camera and so
that's I mean that's what they do with
Iron Man like Robert Downey Jr was
barely wearing yeah like it is it's a
really nice clever way to bridge the gap
yeah fcg in real yeah and just take you
like that final step in the suspension
of disbelief yeah it's just nice yeah
and that was kind of some of that was
informed by like Dean doing the Luke
Skywalker deep fake and stuff and doing
the helmet with the divisor and the chin
strap going up and down yeah that turned
out so well yeah so it's kind of gonna
be like a bit like a more refined
version of that having the actual motion
capture suit and then ideally a prop
helmet because this whole Halo Community
has been amazing being like we'll just
send you stuff and I'm like it's CG but
okay dude it honestly feels like because
of the Halo show yeah you've tapped into
like this this hardened resentment like
it's it's almost uh cathartic for people
to get this kind of content out of the
Halo you know IP again it's and it's
more than the Halo show it's like like
you said you fell off in Halo 4 yeah I
think for a lot of people when and this
is no shade to 343 but like you know
when three four three took over it was
like the original creators of the game
Left Microsoft and then it was like they
were just kind of figuring out ways to
extend the story even though like I
really feel like Master Chief's story
ends at Halo 3 and yeah yeah so like all
these games came out and people were
like and then the show is like the is
like the insult and yeah yeah yeah oh
100 what's interesting with all that
stuff like the minute that you do leave
the Creator and the source of like the
original content you really do lose the
heart of the entire piece and it goes to
show how important writing is obviously
you see with Game of Thrones like when
they when they surpassed the books like
as it had been written they freestyled
and it fell off yeah Halo they
freestyled the show and it fell off Last
of Us guess what they have you know
druckman I think his name is Neil
drugman he's still on board he's helping
guide it and it feels like an expanded
version of the game that's what I've
been saying it's it feels like a
director's cut of the game in the best
way possible because it's like
everything he's maybe been you know
thinking about and kind of going back to
since the game released of like oh man
could I have done this better or now
that this is a film like the biggest
thing for me in episode one was spoiler
alert there's a plane crash instead of a
car crash and you're like yeah oh yeah
he's got a budget like that made me yell
yeah because I I've played the games I
loved the games yeah and I I literally
yeah because I wasn't I was like okay
here comes a car crash
there's still a car crash but then also
they're like but guess what there's a
play and you're like it's those little
changes that just enhance it but it's so
Tethered to the original heart of the
story because the original Creator still
yeah attached to it which uh you know in
contrast the creators of the Halo show
were like we've never played the game
we're doing something different yeah and
it's just yeah imagine if like Last of
Us came out and they're like well you
know we're kind of doing our own thing
with it yeah it just kind of misses the
point of adapting something if you're
not gonna like engage with the source
between exactly well that's also like
just speaking on that like Jonah has
never played a Halo game which is very
important for this I played I played the
knockoff iPad game I know what it was
called hell no I know
I've ever played yeah and but that was
actually really important to me because
I didn't want to get lost in the fandom
that's true I could make my cool master
chief thing and it's like no this like
has to be something that can appeal to
someone that has never watched Halo
before and that was so validating in the
comments on the website and on YouTube
people being like I've never seen any
Halo Media or played any games and this
looks really cool that was that was
everything to me because that's what it
was for me that was my experience like
when I watched that trailer trailer
still that we made like I'm a new fan of
this so I'm looking at I'm just thinking
like this is exciting you know yeah and
when it came to writing it like we were
talking about adaptation like we didn't
want to step on anything that has
already been done in this universe it's
like
yeah because then we don't want Master
achieving this I saw someone that
comment being like Master Chief should
save them at the end oh geez yeah it's
nice to step away yeah and that's what
we're using our own little pocket
because that's the other that's the
other end of it is like you want and
Again Last of Us is a great example it's
like you want to be a fan of the thing
you want to be like uh have a love for
it but then on the other end if you are
way too deep into it you can't see the
force for the trees yeah and there's so
there's so many fan films like and I I
think you guys dodged this really well
but there's so many fan films where it's
like the whole plot is and I mean
honestly a lot of uh like the Marvel
stuff and Star Wars stuff is becoming
this the plot just becomes like here's
the thing you know yeah
yeah totally well I'll say like
Mandalorian incredible I think the
weakest parts of that show are when they
start to tie in like Boba Fett though
they brought in Luke and that was pretty
awesome that stuff's good that like
broke through the yeah like uh here
because it's just it's too powerful and
everybody has relationship with the Star
Wars movies and it's like
but yeah there's but I think Mandalorian
is so good because they started off the
foundation of the show is like we're
doing our own thing just listen to Star
Wars universe and that's that that was
huge inspiration for us with this it's
like we wanted to make something that
theoretically could fit into the Canon
because we're not trying to be like and
this is then Master Chief did this and
this is during this thing we're like
this is just kind of some story that
happens at some random research it has
like self-contained Stakes yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's
that's I think was the flaw of the Halo
TV show they're they're like we're gonna
take the most iconic character the face
of the franchise
and reinvent it and try to tell this
story instead of just being like just
make a new character yeah people would
like it if it wasn't Master Chief do you
think so I'm not so rated well it's got
like 7 out of 10 on IMDb but it's I
think for people that aren't Halo fans
for shows
so I've told you guys this but I sat
down to torture myself and I watched I
think I watched four or five episodes oh
well done and I I had notepad out
because I was like I've heard this is
the worst thing ever like I wanna like
because you know how sometimes you watch
something really bad and you get like
inspired by it yeah I was like I'm gonna
do that with the show and by episode
yeah four I was just broken yeah I was
it was you were out of ink what was the
most egregious part for you
um so they like Halo is a very simple
adventure story it's like you gotta get
the thing to put in the thing and then
you win yeah you know uh it's a video
game and they turn they took the that
universe and tried to like do a Game of
Thrones
take on it where it's like factions are
vying for power and so it was it's like
the UNSC and the scientists and the the
insurgents and then the the
the kind of the stuff that you really
like in Halo which is the the you know I
I think of it as like proper noun
science fiction where it's like the ark
the Covenant it's um all of this cool
like Ancient Aliens stuff with the
um the forerunners like all of that
stuff is just put off to the side and
it's like here's all these human
factions and it's like is Master Chief
really a fascist like what is go any he
has feelings now which is so crazy
because it's like they did that in Halo
2 but it's all in the Covenant yeah like
they do the like the great schism or
whatever and it's like you could have
just had that as like the beep like B
story in the show yeah which they've
already sick because they have a
character called uh McKee who is like
this uh woman child who's adopted by the
Covenant and she's like the chosen one
kind of and so is Master Chief it's
really dumb but uh she kind of cover uh
takes up that story territory of like
Arbiter and Halo 2. which is such a
beautiful storyline because you have
this these parallel stories of Chief and
arbiter who's like questioning his
religion and yeah
um yeah I I think they could have done
Justice to the original Halo story
because again it's not it's not like
it's the best written story but there's
some there's like a kernel in there that
I think we responded to well that's yeah
it could have had the last of us
treatment yeah where it could have been
like you know like the first Halo story
pretty Bare Bones yeah but there's like
there's a good plot there and then
leading into Halo 2 is really where
they're like all right let's expand this
and you get the perspective of the
Covenant really good and I'm like man if
that got the like full-on lasso
streaming where it's like let's just
expand this but not reinvent it yeah
well and then also you know they were
kind of making those games as they went
yeah and scaling it up each time what if
you could start with the end in mind
like a Breaking Bad like something like
that where you know where this is going
so you start the first season and you
can set all those Stakes but like start
again start start small it sounds crazy
to say like a Halo ring and small Stakes
but in the first game it is kind of like
small Stakes it's like yeah I mean it's
kind of end of the universe but it's
like a couple characters you know on a
ring and small stage is not bad like I
think we're all a little tired of
universe ending Stakes anyway yeah I
think everybody right now is like dying
for like remember Spider-Man 2 like the
the stakes
Spider-Man two Spider-Man two or
Spiderman
Andrew Garfield right yeah yeah
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
but remember the end of that movie is
like it's like a city block that's in
danger you know it's but really the
stakes are all of the emotional the
emotional Stakes which is like Peter's
girlfriend's there you know he's had
this relationship with Otto and he's
gone off the deep end and uh you know
there's no blue laser coming down from
the sky or whatever yeah same with Andor
how will we know yeah that's why there's
a great example of that yeah yeah that's
why I love Daredevil like Daredevil's
great yeah because he's like yeah it's
like Yeah The Avengers whatever I'm just
here for Hell's Kitchen yeah yeah and we
do the reality is we just don't we don't
need we don't need world ending Stakes
it's nice and you know going back to
kind of not staying true to the source
material with the Halo show I my jaw
dropped when I saw Master Chief's face
immediately I was like
remember in the game like the tease of
him taking off the helmet and it being
obscured and I was like screaming as a
kid I was like yeah have you ever seen
the video somebody uh broke the camera
so they could keep it in the in the ship
and it takes off his helmet and it's
just his helmet underneath
and there's another element underneath
that is incredible I haven't seen that
that's amazing but yeah it's like that
that kind of stuff like already that's
not my master chief yeah immediately not
mine that's not my master and it's like
they had the template right there of the
Mandalorian like just dude I think they
were too worried to be uh you know it's
crazy though because it's like they got
the original voice actor for Cortana Jen
Taylor and it's like it's just against
Steve Downs to do the master chief just
keeps helming them great and Cortana in
the show Cortana is kind of like a
villain a little bit because she's like
spying on Master Chief which is I don't
know I think it's funny Mandalorian not
only just because they have a character
with a helmet but like this and Last of
Us same thing the the wolf and and Cub
kind of storyline of like this person
guiding a defense uh defenseless you
know character it's that's what's Halos
yeah because Cortana is like the key to
everything and cheap has to get her
somewhere yeah so what we need is Pedro
Pascal as Master Chiefs
man no yeah because he doesn't have to
be in the suit most of the time yeah get
someone else too so right so he just is
like gets to be the voice actor yeah
that's amazing but I will say the you
know the VFX in that show a lot of them
are really cool and Halo yeah from what
I've seen like like to the environment
work is incredible it's like the effects
themselves are really good the
filmmaking approach to the show is so
Bland yeah and boring CW yeah yeah yeah
it's like 100 which and it's jarring
because you'll go from like one
damn like some huge wide pushing it on a
city or like that looks incredible and
then you cut in and then it's like
locked off camera in like a set that's
like and then Cortana pops up and it's
like hi and you're just like oh I hate
to say this is how I that's how I felt
about the Lord of the Rings show oh I
watched like the first episode and I was
like there's like this cool sweeping
environment shot and then they cut into
a close-up of a character and it's just
like I'm just watching actors talk yeah
filmmaking going on here I can kind of
see that although to a lesser degree
certainly I enjoyed I'm a Lord of the
Rings
child at heart like that was right that
was my you're a little star wars that
was I'm a little hobbit on the inside
yeah if I take off my feet just covered
in hair like you can't say Hobbit
anymore it's hard foot now thank you
Fenner geez Louise this guy come on
catch up uh but yeah the Lord let me
show I can see that too like there were
there were moments where granted they
poured so much money into it it did look
like a little bit cwe too to me
Halo was 10 million dollars enough that
was wild that's great and we were
talking like we were watching we sat
down and just watched the blur Halo 2
Anniversary so good like the scene where
Chief um he's like giving the Covenant
back their bombs yeah he takes the bomb
and goes the other ship uh like that
looked better than everything in the
Halo show even though it's all CG yeah
and it's all the filmmaking it's all
yeah you're so right the cameras are are
tied to like re you know it's like which
you kind of took that approach with this
uh that was that's been a huge thing
with ours is like we don't have any
floating cameras it has to be a shot
that you could feasibly get like the the
shot through the tank we had a whole
conversation about that in the trailer
but there's like this camera that
there's like the fractured tank and
we're pushing through and you see the
people walking infinite was like where
where would the camera be how are they
doing this shot and I'd like justify the
camera system that would like work right
I was like no you could do it yeah it
was like a jib and like Jonah had to
convince me of his camera
rigs he's like yeah so if we did like a
jib arm and we did this we could pull it
off I'm like all right I'll do it yeah
and then blender you're like two key
frames yeah yeah but it's like when
you're God you know in your program and
you can do anything yeah it's less about
what you can do and it's more like why
yeah having restraint that was a
the like we rewatched Avatar and then
watched Avatar 2 and there's some
moments in that movie are so sick
because they feel so grounded and then
you get a shot where it's like floating
camera that flies and you're like oh
okay it is weirdly removes all the
stakes of the whole thing like in
superhero movies I see it all the time
yeah and it just all of a sudden doesn't
feel grounded okay now there's no danger
and it's just literally a choice on
camera in those moments in Avatar 2
where it's like handheld looking and
you're like dude what was it when the
the uh when they blew up the forest and
there was like the the ships were
parachuting down and it's like you see
his lens Distortion those are like some
of the most incredible shots I've seen
in my entire life yeah I was like the
Navi on the horses like going through
like the no no when they first come and
they're just like scorching them come
back and they're like we're you guys
think you can mess with us yeah
um
no yeah uh but it's that's an
interesting thing is like it doesn't
matter how good the effects are if it
feels floaty and it feels like it can be
as sharp and crisp as you want but like
uh I think of the you guys remember the
the Battle Star Galactica remake from
the early 2000s like that show the
effects look really bad now but it still
feels good because there's like there's
the uh whip Zooms in space and it feels
like somebody's shooting from the
cockpit of one of the uh Fighters it's
yeah it feels like as a VFX it does hurt
to say this because I love visual
effects and I will often go to movies
just to see visual effects because I
just love the Artistry in it but it
feels like the other elements like I
think of RR right
that story was serviced by some good VFX
and some that was like just filling the
Gap yeah the creature stuff it's like
decent but you can tell it's CG but it's
it's purely there to serve as a story
that you are fully in and you are so
committed to the story that doesn't
matter like throw it in there versus
Halo great visual effects on this thing
that you don't like you can't you can't
adhere those two together in the same
way yeah and Sam and Nick will talk
about this all the time but it's like
does it it does it's not successful
unless it's getting the idea across yeah
and then on the flip side if it gets the
idea across you're pretty much done like
you can you can take it to 60 70 and
it's still especially you know for stuff
we make on YouTube it like gets the idea
across whereas yeah if it's just oh look
at all this pretty window dressing yeah
there's no you know real need to it then
yeah I mean
no no no oh gosh I'm triggered yeah
we've had the intervention in this room
right here it's like only I'm getting
the meat sweats
yeah I mean as far as VFX obviously this
whole thing is visual effects like how
percentage-wise how far you along to
having like a finish thing because I I
think there's talks of us all jumping on
it which I'm like super eager and I
would love to uh but where are you now
in the like the grand scheme I don't
know maybe 20 yeah
oh wow I was actually expecting like 60.
no
okay and here's the problem yeah it gets
incrementally more difficult oh because
well I don't want to give spoilers away
but like what we have set up I'm gonna
I'm thinking really hard so I don't say
anything
what we have set up is going to work for
a lot of it but there's some stuff
towards the end that is like really high
level stuff that is going to need a lot
of love one hand animation probably yeah
because it's like in the plates and
that's gonna take time yeah you know and
and those elements all happen in the
last
five pages of it yeah and I guess like
three pages like that it's that's when
we need everything yeah and I guess
there's also the idea of the animation
not really taking place until you have
final performance yeah because that
would obviously influence your actions
in the Rococo suit yeah totally yeah so
yeah it's like I don't know
there's probably yeah of finished
footage we probably have like three
minutes of a 10 minute piece so yeah
maybe like 30 I don't know heck yeah but
but having said that all the
environments are set up all the
characters are set up so then it's just
a matter of setting the shots up
rendering them yeah it's like feels like
a lot left to do but then it's just like
you know if you did
I don't know how many shots there are
left but if you do like one or two shots
a day just after work then I'm like
sweet it's just done in a few months
yeah yeah if you think about it's like
we we had some stuff done we had been
like slow cooking on but like the amount
of stuff that we got through in two
weeks if you if we roll with that
it wouldn't take that long to finish
yeah you know because that's a quarter
that we did I broke down our full shot
list and I was like if it's just me
working on it like
conservatively it would be like 50 days
of work oh really yeah but that's like
that's honestly in the span of a year
like that's not that bad yeah like yeah
and that's just like
that was being you know that's if I'm
finishing like two or three shots a day
which I you know once you're just doing
like dialogue shots in the interior it's
like you can start to rip through stuff
yeah and like you said you set up all
the environments and stuff are ready to
to move super quick like granted it's a
much much smaller scale but for like the
mobile game ad we had however many shots
it was it was like a minute of purely
animated 14 characters like yeah there's
a lot and like facial animation with
models that were not rigged at all and
so like yeah step one was rig all the
characters procedurally switch those
rigs out to the other characters and
once all the set is built once all the
characters are built in a full range of
Animation is possible to you then you
pour it into the funnel and it expedites
the whole thing super super quick so
it's not a shot by shot basis you've
already built the 60 yeah that you need
to send it the rest of the way and you
like you speed up on your way out and
it's very encouraging in the workflow
um but it sounds like that's kind of the
situation you're in yeah like nice by
the end of like the two weeks I was
working on the trailer it's like shots
were coming together in like an hour
from like
opening the blender scene to final like
render that's awesome really nice you're
doing that trick where you're doing
multiple cameras so you could have one
scene one file and you were just setting
up every camera yeah we would have our
mocap take and then he could just rip
fire off like five cameras render each
one and yeah it's pretty pretty light
yeah um so it's also just fun to work on
because I'm like cool I just get to make
a cool Halo render yeah but then at the
end it's like oh sweet it's all pieces
together into a cool story yeah yeah so
that's like fun to just slow burn on
honestly I'm curious what you've learned
along the way on the CG side of things
as far as workflow like going in and
coming out now what are some of the
lessons you've learned from man so so so
so so much like
I'm still fairly new to blender
um so just learning how to just optimize
scenes render settings to just like get
rid of Flickr how to like make something
go through quickly like because it was
getting to the point like albeit we do
awesome computers from Puget but like
some of the scenes I've got down so it's
like three seconds of frame almost crazy
for like all the Cycles through Cycles
some of them but also Evie then you can
get some like it was like crazy it's
like almost real time playback and stuff
like I was showing you some of the
environments where like moving the
camera around with depth of field on in
real time because they're gay like
you're saying it's game assets yeah oh
so they're like fully optimized yeah
what's like is this such a dumb and
nerdy question but I am genuinely
curious like polygon count for a
character what are we talking do you
know offhand oh the characters are
actually pretty dense oh I think that's
definitely what they put the most time
into but like the environments and stuff
it's like it's crazy you can just load
that up and it's really easy that's
awesome other things I've learned just
in the just blocking like that's been
huge for Joan and I like we've been
using shot deck
um which was made during the creation of
the The Joker movie Joker
um where it's basically like a bunch of
super high quality Stills that you can
just search it's a great basically it's
a search engine for cinematography oh
that's cool like what descriptors do you
type in to find images dude anything you
want like low angle
left left heavy red majority 60 red 30
blue low angle with a man with a beard
what yeah and it's just the highest
quality still from a movie and then they
add they add images every week they also
have like a really cool Forum on there
it was made by the DP of the Joker who
just got fed up of trying to find images
and he's like I'm just gonna make it and
he made it and it it you have to pay for
it but how much
if you're interested in creating your
own stuff and really want to find
reference imagery it's the best dude
yeah I the the reason I quit commercial
directing was because of the pitch
packets that you have to make yeah you
have to make pitch package for every job
that you bid on and sometimes it takes
days and a lot of those days is just
finding imagery that supports your
vision to try and sell it to a client
yeah and it's so demoralizing trying to
go on Google Images and find images yeah
yeah that sounds like an incredible
resource yeah
like they didn't have every time I go on
there there's like a new little tool
that you can refine your searches with
and then you can build decks in there
and then download those and share them
with people and make notes in there and
so dude that now that and then text the
image yeah text the image yeah whatever
you want yeah
dude that doesn't think about that
that's literally what we did for um for
the mobile game ad we had picture frames
yeah and I threw a picture of a horse in
there and I was like haha horse right it
was fine uh and then Matt's like
actually we might not be able to use
that image where did you get it and we
had like three minutes of conversation
and then we're like duh dude let's just
freaking make one so horse images and
you just generate them and stick them in
man it's such a great
just for pre-visualizing stuff we've
talked about this before but like that
was the best time to be doing this
because like you have everything you
could ever imagine it's intimidating too
because it's like you know when when
like Score says he was making his movies
he didn't have like an amazing computer
in the entire internet and he still made
the stuff so then it's like is it a
crutch or is it a tool you just have to
yeah but you go back on watch Mean
Streets that's a Jank
imagine if you had blender imagine if
yeah dude I wonder you put like Score
says he's born 2000
or 2000 year 2000 does he do it
practically or is he like a VFX artist
now in in the in the way things are
because he was a go-getter and he he his
first movie is like he was making by
himself and trying to get done and
that's what we're doing yeah and like
which route would he go I think he had
the tools whatever tools are available
to to get it done yeah but yeah it's
funny now those guys are all old and
they're like so judgmental yeah
yeah there's like the greatest lessons
I've learned from just the ground up is
and I say it all the time is use the
tool for the job
like it makes everything infinitely
easier yeah don't try to necessarily
shoehorn unless of course resources
unavailable and you have what you have
that's totally fine but yeah using the
right tool for the job and not trying to
necessarily Master every corner of a
software like learning what you need to
learn for the task at hand is an awesome
way to learn everything as you go yeah
and it's kind of sometimes it's like the
only way you really are gonna learn
because you retain it because you have a
memory Tethered to it it's like locking
it in it's like oh the time where I was
pulling my hair out for two days I'm not
gonna forget that I'm not gonna forget
the solution that I found to that that's
like a core memory now and you build
enough for those like finna you're
saying from the minute you started to
the minute you're at now how much you've
learned in blender yeah and it's all
Tethered to like Memories you know yes
it's a different way of learning that's
really really good I always think that's
the best way to learn is to start doing
something because
doesn't work for me to be like I'm going
to learn this it's like I have to have a
reason to learn I have Stakes I'm gonna
learn what every button here does yeah
with no context yeah it's like but how
do I use those buttons to actually do
something yeah that's what I need
man that's awesome yeah and uh I mean
another thing I'm curious about is
obviously we know JC we know Brett from
the channel but Herman yeah like how did
that come about who is Herman like how
did you guys meet how did he get
involved in the department as a huge
Corridor fan who also happens to be an
incredibly successful actor he's uh the
star of the Netflix show Ragnarok he was
on this huge Norwegian show called scam
which I actually watched like many years
back uh and he just came by the studio
uh he was in LA for some meetings and he
was like Hey I would love to Come mute
the team and he just came by and hung
out and he was like the nicest dude he
was lovely yeah he's like the coolest
dude we love you Herman yeah me and JC
and Matt we just went out for some
drinks and dinner with him and we just
started talking about like projects we
wanted to do and stuff and I was like
Matt had been helping us shoot like some
previous for it with JC and so we just
started talking about he's like are you
guys talking about Halo he's like I love
Halo and so we're like no way dude and
he's like dude he did some game streams
actually yeah he he's like setting up
Twitch streaming and stuff uh like he's
is it just a gamer man like and he's big
quarter fan and he's an incredible actor
so he was just like can I do this with
you guys and we're like yes does he know
he took my job yeah yeah for those of
you don't know oh I'm in the previous
two yeah yeah we haven't created a
couple really fun nights yeah shooting
iPhone previous with you we pulled late
nights these guys bought us food yeah
and we hung out until like nine or ten
at night and we shot the whole thing
practically as like reference yeah uh to
match with the CG cameras and some of it
got tracked to some degree I think yeah
yeah but uh that is are we ever gonna
release that like after the whole thing
we should do that um like that's the
quarter crude
I don't know between
the intervention scene that we shot with
you in that night those are the two
funniest yeah the most times I've left
dude you were killing it bro here's the
here's the issue that I have in life and
it's a real problem this is a medical
issue I can't do anything seriously
nothing in my life that I've touched I
can be serious with I did uh my first
project in at Chapman film school I
poured myself into and I was like I'm
gonna make something dramatic and
compelling and I want to be the guy that
everyone looks to in the class and goes
wow
filmmaker so I brought on some actors
like I put together a whole scene and it
was about this this uh this dad who was
lamenting the fact that he was out of
money and it's revealed that he's
lamenting over his daughter's piggy bank
and he decides to break it and take the
money inside for whatever it is you know
fill in the blanks and it builds this
pivotal scene where this guy's going
nuts and then it reveals the piggy bank
and the wide as he's about to smash it
and everybody in the class started
laughing when it revealed the piggy bank
and it broke as the piggy bank broke so
too did I but what I did was I pretended
it was supposed to be funny
uh and so I leaned into it and ever
since then I was like I just commit like
I can't do anything serious so Herman
you belong in that role brother like if
you see the footage that I'm in
you'll agree as well getting multiple
Parts in the
previously yeah
you were JC for a bit yeah
well that was born for that one that was
a mistake
it's hard to do something sincerely like
yeah that's like one of the things that
we've has been a founding idea with this
project it's like there was a couple
times I was like what if he said this
would be kind of funny in terms like no
yeah yeah I was like yeah you're right
let's let's stay true to our value here
like we're not trying to make a joke
it's not there are no punch lines yeah
like we're doing something with
sincerity and that's real hard yeah
because if it falls flat it falls flat
yeah I did I had a similar experience
like freshman year of film School 48
Hour film fest
got real serious it was in black and
white oh you did it
you did the college thing and it was
like a group it was like a Noir you know
and we were like it was real good you
know yeah and we they rented at an AMC
theater oh my god oh wow like the whole
program was there and not the whole
program but everyone who wanted to do
the 40 Hour film festival was there and
it was
this noise after so just absolute
silence just not even collapsed it was
like
and I got such a massive chip on my
shoulder from that that I like came back
the next year and I was like I'm gonna
make something funny because everyone
loved everything that was funny won yeah
I was like [__] you guys let's go and at
the end of it it was this sound
dude we won oh you won okay great so
Vindicated
but what then it taught me was like oh
yeah I'll just be funny now I'll just be
funny I'll make you made this
mockumentary and I was like hahaha and
everyone's like oh that was awesome no
and like it was really frustrating
because on the one hand I was like so
proud of it but on the other I was like
like I bent the knee you still got that
chip to the god of of the crutch of just
making someone laugh well that's the
thing is you know I've heard over and
over again it said that comedy is
actually the hardest genre to pull off
because obviously it's so subjective and
to some degree I can totally see that
being the case but I've always had the
utmost respect for drama so you guys
putting together something that is
really compelling and like gets you hype
is to me that is like the ultimate and
it's super impressive what you guys have
done so far so yeah I know yeah we don't
want the whole thing to be like Grim
dark like oh we gotta go in there and
save the world like there's there's
Gallows humor like there is
it's not just complete like try hard
slime yeah as long as it's like coming
from the characters in that situation
because like I feel like that's again
the problem with most modern movies
especially the modern the Marvel movies
is like the comedy comes from a kind of
not like Deadpool level of
self-awareness but like a awareness that
like hey you're watching this movie
isn't this wacky dude that's like I got
a bow I know yeah and you're like in in
stranger things she's like oh he's
Spider-Man does it come out of his butt
and you're just like
say this in this situation actually and
I feel like yeah it's so rare now that
people because it's just yeah people are
so cynical on it uh it's it's so
refreshing when people just
swing you know take a big swing and
that's what you guys are doing just like
take it seriously you know and let me be
clear
if it's bad
it was funny the whole time yeah yeah
yeah
even this
yeah that's the best way to tell a joke
is with a straight face because you can
always get out of it and act like you
were serious yeah you didn't get it like
that joke you didn't laugh at that joke
but now look I'm serious still so are is
it your fault you're gonna think about
that all night and I'm gonna move on
so yeah tricks of the tricks of the
trade there you can have that that's
free yeah um but yeah I I mean we're all
super hyped by it we're all like super
eager to jump on if that you know if we
get to that point and I guess timeline
wise for people who are wondering like
when are we gonna see the final thing I
don't know that's been another thing is
I don't want to put a date on it because
I don't want to rush it and it's like I
want it
that we in some ways because it is
something we're working on in our free
time we have the luxury to finish it
when it like it's done when it's done
um
which is
you know I I hate
that some stuff has to be rushed out and
it's like
I don't want to put a date on it because
I just want it to be the best it can be
well and it's I bet it's also just very
uh like therapeutic as like and you know
we I love the stuff we put out here but
it's like week after week it's like it's
Friday time to put out a video yeah yeah
and sometimes it's just so nice to work
on something with no deadline or and
like at some point you know you got to
put a deadline on it but yeah like to
just have this expansive like let's you
know because that the experimentation is
where the really deep you know uh
moments in a piece come from it's like
we tried all these routes and we found
the perfect one where it's like honestly
like scooty like what Peter did yeah I
you know if he had been like I have to
have this done in two months it wouldn't
be as incredible as it is yeah he really
poured himself into that one yeah and
it's like
I think with some people you need to
have that firm deadline or it'll never
get done but I'm just like I'm so happy
to just keep working on this like that
eventually like when it gets to a point
where it's like it's done then I want to
put the deadline on it to be like okay
it's done now let's finish it which was
like when we did the spiderverse thing
that was so cool we had a version done
they're like let's just polish it yeah
and that's where you I think the best
work comes through and yeah yeah so I'm
just gonna keep working on it I think
mostly just in my free time and stuff
and then whenever there's an opportunity
for us to be like hey this thing's
pretty
Sweet let's finish it and we'll do that
you guys are now the George RR Martin's
of the studio just cruising yeah but I
mean I'll just say like all the support
um from the corridor audience and just
from the general Halo audience has been
like so cool and so externally
validating and uh
I appreciate you all oh
love Yeah Jonas likewise man it's um you
know you you we've spent months
here in the studio upstairs convincing
ourselves that this was a good idea
um and to have a bunch of people there
are so many comments that people are
saying like I got chills watching this
yeah and the first time that I was
editing the beginning of the trailer I
did have chills I was so [__] hyped
yeah and I was like waiting to show
Fenner and I showed him and he's like
this is awesome and then you know you
work on it over and over and over and
over again and you know becomes numb you
just get hit with it over the face and
then you you hate it some nights and you
left the next night dude by the time we
released it I was like I think this is
so bad yeah like it was awful when we
were showing Sam and Nico I'm like oh
[__] they hate it
and so you know
I I told you this the night we finished
the trailer we're driving home and I
said I don't really care what happens
after this I was riding such a high we
were jamming to Tunes in the car and I
said this is why I made the trailer
because we just clicked export and I'm
proud of our work and then to have
everyone truly love it was it was
overwhelming yeah yeah it was like it
was amazing yeah yeah it was really cool
so we'll just keep working on it it'll
be done uh when it's done because I I
don't want to put a deadline on it
that's fair enough man but it won't be
like it won't be like three years from
now it'll probably be like this year too
so cool like four years so well that's
good enough I yeah I think when we get
to the point where we're all jumping on
board it's gonna be then we can really
yeah yeah bring it home no spoilers but
there are some simulations yeah it might
be a big old Houdini
I was like
how excited
thanks for chatting guys and thanks for
watching or listening everybody
um therapeutic very therapeutic this
whole entire process we're resurrecting
Halo you know in a beautiful way and uh
I'm all about it dude yeah yeah so uh
yeah I mean I guess you know you heard
it here you'll you'll see it when you
see it but it shouldn't be too much
longer no and then we'll have it out but
yeah and and here throw your theories in
the in the comments yeah do me a favor
yeah watch that trailer again tell us
what you think the story is about and if
it's if it's right or better
than what we already written what do
they get you get a writer credit to
watch it
I know throw your ideas because um you
know part of this trailer is trying to
show what this story could be and a lot
of people have responded really
positively to that yeah and they're
already theorizing one of my favorite
comments like trailer is really cool but
I don't really understand what's going
on and then they listed all the story
beats and I was like no you do
it's a trailer you don't want to give
the whole thing away like but I was like
oh they picked up everything we were
trying to get across like without
completely like tipping our hat to what
the story is yeah but it was that was
hilarious to me I was like
well there you go comment down below and
uh we'll see you next time in the
meantime we're gonna get back to our
singing I think should we sing oh yeah
we have an alternative song We can
probably fade out while we sing this one
but this one's a special one near and
dear to my heart
Meat Man
champion of the pan
covered in crumbs and stuff he's the
best man